In this segment,
we're going to go over
a few theoretical properties of
the estimation error in least
mean squares estimation.
Recall that our least
mean squares estimator
is the conditional expectation
of the unknown random variable,
given our observations.
Let us define the
error, which is
the difference
between the estimator
and the random variable that
we are trying to estimate.
Let us start with
some observations.
What is the expected
value of our estimator?
Well, using the law of
iterated expectations,
the expectation of a
conditional expectation
is the same as the
unconditional expectation.
And using this property,
by moving this Theta
to the other side,
what we obtain
is that the estimation error
has an expectation of 0.
So this tells us that
the estimation error,
on the average, is equal
to 0, which is good news.
In fact, something
stronger is true.
Not just the overall average
of the estimation error is 0,
but even if you condition on a
particular measurement, still
the conditional expectation
of your estimation error
is going to be equal to 0.
Let us derive this relation.
We're looking at the expected
value of Theta tilde, which
is Theta hat minus Theta,
conditional on a value of X.
Now, if I tell you
the value of X,
then the estimator is
completely determined--
there's no
uncertainty about it--
so the expectation of Theta hat,
in this conditional universe,
is just Theta hat itself.
And we're left with
the second term,
but the second term
is also Theta hat,
and therefore we obtain
a difference of 0.
Let us now move to a slightly
more complicated question.
What is the covariance
between the estimation
error and the estimate?
We will calculate the
covariance as follows.
It is the expected
value of the product
of the two random variables
that we are interested in,
minus the product of
their expectations.
Now, we already calculated
that the expected value
of the estimation
error is equal to 0,
and therefore, this
term here disappears.
This term is equal to 0.
So we now need to
calculate the first term.
This may seem difficult,
but conditioning is always
a great trick, so let's do that.
Let us start by calculating
the conditional expectation
of this product.
As before, in the
conditional universe,
where we're told the value
of X, the value of Theta hat
is known.
It is becoming a
constant, so it can
be pulled outside
the expectation.
But then we can apply the fact
that we established earlier
that this term is 0, and
therefore, we obtain a 0 here.
Now, the expected value
of a random variable
is the same as
the expected value
of the conditional expectation.
This is, again, the law
of iterated expectations.
Since the conditional
expectation is 0,
when we apply the law
of iterated expectations
to this quantity,
we also obtain a 0.
Therefore, this
term is 0 as well,
and we have established
what we wanted to show.
Using this fact, now
we can figure out
that the following is true.
We write the random
variable Theta
as the sum of Theta
hat minus Theta tilde.
This comes simply from
this definition here,
by just moving
Theta to this side,
and Theta tilde
to the other side.
So Theta is the difference
of two random variables,
and these two random
variables have 0 covariance.
When two random variables
have 0 covariance,
then the variance of their
sum, or of their difference,
is the sum of the variances.
And this leads us
to this relation--
that the variance of
our random variable
can be decomposed
into two pieces.
One of them is the
variance of the estimator,
and the other is the variance
of the estimation error.
This is an interesting fact.
It can actually be derived
in a different way, as well.
It is just a manifestation of
the law of total variances,
but hidden in somewhat
different notation.
And this concludes
our discussion
of theoretical properties
of the estimation error.
Unfortunately we will
not have the opportunity
to use them in any
interesting ways.
On the other hand, they
are a foundational piece
for the more general theory
of least-squares estimation.
If you try to develop it in
a more sophisticated and more
deep way, it turns out
that these properties
are cornerstones of that theory.